c'est un secret de polichinelle dans son
édition de dimanche le Wall Street
Journal l'assure Jake Sullivan conseillé
à la sécurité nationale de Joe Biden
c'est récemment et à plusieurs reprises
entre tenues avec deux hauts
responsables russes l'intérêt c'est
confirmant public oui
l'administration byden avons eu
l'occasion de dialoguer à de très haut
niveau avec les Russes pour réduire les
risques et faire-part des conséquences
de l'utilisation potentielle d'armes
nucléaires
ces deux interlocuteurs selon le
quotidien américain Nicolas patron de
chef à la tête du Conseil de défense
russe et Yuri uchakov conseiller en
politique étrangère au Kremlin de proche
collaborateurs de Vladimir Poutine donc
qui aurait son oreille d'où l'intérêt de
ce canal téléphonique pour Washington
très inquiet depuis que le Président
russe a menacé d'utiliser l'arme
nucléaire en Ukraine
interroger sur ses révélations le
Kremlin lui préfère beauté en touche
nous n'avons rien à dire sur cette
publication des journaux anglo-saxons
publient beaucoup de mensonges vous
devez contacter soit le journal soit la
Maison Blanche
instaurer au plus fort de la guerre
froide après la crise des missiles de
Cuba de 1962 ce téléphone rouge permet
depuis à Washington et Moscou de
discuter directement des sujets
sensibles la menace nucléaire brandie
par Vladimir Poutine en est assurément
un
[Musique]